you're asking me how i can stay friends
with women i've slept with like back in
when we were in college right we we did
that
i told her i'd stop saying the story you
know i'm not gonna do it no i'm gonna do
it [ __ ] it what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus
[Music]
you guys we just had our guest on the
show right before this intro
and he's
actually hysterical hysterical he's
coming back for the second time on the
unwax podcast i cannot wait for you guys
to hear this interview it's so great but
we're just gonna you know
do a little weekly update yeah talk see
what's happening i got a very exciting
package in the mail the other day
um i decided to order
the cookie game from squid games i
almost want to play with the apartment
and just there has to be a punishment
for the loser yeah just keep the song on
repeat for an hour while we're trying to
like figure it out or we can do it by it
till the game ends or the song what
should we wager if someone cracks the
cookie
i guess death is the appropriate answer
jesus christine
death by what
we could put you in the fireplace it
doesn't work though it's broken the [ __ ]
so actually i'll take it if i lose
sophia why did you write two men and a
bird yeah let me get around to that you
were just starting okay so i think this
is a better update while i was on the
way to a gym that i just signed up for
i was uh in front of this car with these
two men in this giant suv and they
looked pretty scary like they looked
like muscle heads like it was they were
at least like six five like their
their forearms were as big as like
my legs put together they were just
giant
and they're just sitting there like with
the crazy goatee and mustache
and
out of nowhere
this freaking parakeet
comes from behind him in between and
lands on their steering wheel no way and
they're looking at the bird and they're
laughing and they're like petting it and
the bird like looks at them pauses
chirps and you see them hysterically
cracking up this bird is jumping on
their shoulders it was just so funny and
i was crying laughing seeing these giant
giant muscle men well there's something
about seeing a really big man with a
really tiny animal cracking up at this
parakeet out of nowhere it was a pretty
little like green and yellow parakeet
i'm like what is this i want to touch on
the fact that you just signed up for a
gym yeah you always roasted me for i
never roasted you for a gym no this is
what you always made fun of me for you
said sistine why do you get ready for
the gym why do you try why do you put on
a little bit of makeup for the gym and
then sophia comes back always say that
you did no and you come back and you go
yeah no now i need to try i actually
have to get ready for the gym now
because there's attractiveness yes
so i'm i'm so i love going to the gym
now i work out 10 times harder and i am
10 times more sore than i've ever been
in my life did i tell you so yeah but
the thing is is that i don't but that's
not the point i'm saying that i think i
have slight gym anxiety because i don't
like
not being perfect at the gym like if i
am weightlifting i want to make sure
that i don't look like the idiot that's
standing there with me
because if i'm gonna work this is the
thing if i'm gonna be looking cute at
the gym which i in general like to look
good when they work out it just kind of
motivates me in extras
i don't know why
but if i'm that girl that looks cute at
the gym and doesn't know what she's
doing it just embarrasses me and i know
that i shouldn't be but i don't want to
be that girl i know and i also hate
being that girl that thinks that people
are actually staring at me at the gym
when they're definitely just doing their
own workout yeah i stare at people
i start everyone at the gym i'm actually
probably like it's kind of bad i
definitely am that person that i think
people are checking me out but it's
because i'm staring at them
i don't mean to i honestly think you're
going to meet someone at the gym i don't
think so actually that'd be cute but i
don't think anyone would come up to me
because people don't go you would be
surprised i don't i think your gym they
would my gym they wouldn't my gym's a
little aggressive they're a little
aggressive where your your hood is at
but i think it's because there's been
this thing where you know in general
when i'm working out don't approach me i
don't honestly like to be approached and
i don't think you love to be approached
either i hate it right like you're
working out you're getting sweaty you're
getting fit you don't want someone be
like hey nice squat it's like get the
[ __ ] like come on like that oh you know
what really annoys me too when you sign
up for a big gym and the people that
work there
try to sell you on
you working with them to be your trainer
and then you have to start paying them
extra on top of the really expensive
monthly payment they have to pay the gym
i always get the trainers there saying
like you know i was looking at you from
afar and like your form is really good
at what are you trying to work on oh i
could help you do that i'm like a glute
specialist i'm like hold on i know what
i'm doing i've seen about 900 000
youtube videos of how to squat i don't
need your help how to squat and then
they follow you and then they take your
number and then they text you and it's
like oh this is the thing how do you say
no men or ladies if you're trying to
approach a girl at a gym this is what i
would say
first
be consistent if you're seeing her a
couple times and the energy seems no no
because i give two looks and you can
tell there's the stop looking at me look
and then then there's the i'm absolutely
checking you out look if there's a
longing if i'm just like looking you up
and down
if you know like i agree but is that
weird no but then to go to the gym to
pick up people that's i don't see if
that's i don't go to the gym to pick up
i'm not saying you do i'm saying other
people no no one goes to the gym i mean
i hope you guys don't go to the gym to
pick up people but i don't think people
are going to the gym to pick up people i
think if you see someone that likes to
work out you like to work out that's a
commonality you guys like fitness but
sometimes i'm at the gym like oh that
guy has he's like in shape he's cute um
yeah like that i wouldn't mind him
approaching me what i would do and i
would suggest is let it ride out like
you guys can look at each other maybe
smile at each other like eventually like
kind of warm it up and then maybe
go off to the side because there's like
a balcony and there's some places you
can kind of stand to get somebody's like
just stand on the balcony let your hair
fall down and he'll come up for you from
you're the worst grab your spandex
spandex all right sistine um but yeah no
i'm just saying like that would be a way
but
overall 99 um yeah i just don't like
it's funny because you started dressing
up at the gym and i'm like i don't try
anymore
and i love it i it's just the initial
stages of a new gym you're like i feel
like it's a new school it's like a
relationship no it's like going to a new
high school you're going in you're a
freshman you're fresh meat everyone
there has been there for a couple years
meat you're fresh meat everyone's there
everyone kind of knows each other i'm
coming in
new kid on the block
and they're all looking at me sizing me
up what is she wearing
what is she benching
benching how long is she here for
10 minutes
you just have that little anxiety and
you just want to look good
i love it though
my throat just went away
no but i love it though i think it's why
are you laughing at me can i just like
mess up for a second without you
cracking up no i just like i felt like a
dust just went into my throat and i like
um just died oh i love that we still
have halloween she's cobwebs i noticed
that during our interview we have holla
it looks like happy halloween
people complex
unboxed it hasn't been used in years
oh lord we're so crazy i know i feel
delusional um
i've i've noticed that i've been sleep
talking again how have you noticed
you've been sleep talking sistine
you're so foul for that
i i wake myself up
from sleep talking yes
oh my god you know
do you remember when we were kids stop
looking at the cobwebs focus
do you remember when we were kids
are so freaky they just like stay in the
air and they don't move
how are you still floating it's so
freaky anyway we'll leave him gravity
uh anyway focus okay we're back um
stop okay go ahead go ahead and die
sophia is this bad habit where
if i say sophia don't turn around now
but look at this blah blah blah behind
you she will literally turn right when
i'm telling her not to turn so the fact
that there's little cobwebs flying
around i know you're not looking at me
your eyes are darting everywhere else
but me but try to stay focused i know
now
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
when we were kids sophina i used to
share a room
and we would both sleep talk quite a bit
a lot oh yeah a lot and we realized that
say if i was sleep talking as a child
sophia would ask me questions and i
would give honest answers while sleep
talking and then i'd wake up the next
day and you'd know everything about me
you know my crushes
yeah there is a lot of negative negative
parts of joining club volleyball i hated
it the one good thing that i learned was
the sleep talking trick while i was on
one of these away camps or whatever it
was i hated clifford my friend told me
that if your friend is mumbling if
someone's mumbling in their sleep that
means they're having a pretty shallow
dream they're almost like lucid dreaming
a little bit and that's a time where you
can ask them a yes and no question so i
used to do it to all of my girlfriends
we did one of my friends cat shout out
if you're listening and i remember we
were just asking her like who she had a
crush on and all this stuff and she
remembers it no she doesn't remember it
but she like knows about this the next
day and we thought it was hilarious so i
was doing it to sistine and i found out
all these things about her so if you
ever are living with someone and they're
sleep talking wake them up like a little
bit when they're in this delirious state
and ask them questions and they will be
in they will answer if it's a yes or no
because they can nod and shake their
head
you know yeah so that's what it is and i
do that to you and i hope someone's
doing that to you because that'd be
funny well i did wake up sophia in the
midst of her sleep talking the other
night and do you know what you said to
me wait what yeah you don't remember you
were sleep talking and i went into your
room and do you know what you said to me
no
you said
manscaped
and i was like what
i said that
manscaped is our sponsor this week on
the podcast baby that's right so seeing
the reason why i said this in my sleep
is because all i want for this holiday
season is for my man to have smooth
jingle balls yes you guys and guess what
manscaped can answer my prayers with the
performance package 4.0 so i don't have
to find santa's beard in my man's pants
again
that would be alarming yes ladies this
holiday season get your man products
that will leave him smelling fresh with
their all new ultra premium body wash
and a two in one shampoo and conditioner
it's time to give the man
in your life the gift of beautiful skin
hair
and balls this holiday season girls i
don't know about you but i'm tired of
finding a bush when i go down on my
man's chimney it's gross and it doesn't
do anything for anyone hairy jingle
balls are a thing of the past with the
manscaped performance package 4.0 inside
the performance package 4.0 you will
find the signature lawnmower 4.0 this
electric trimmer has proprietary
advanced skin safe technology the
perfect trimmer to keep his christmas
tree trimmed
it's also waterproof
so he can use it in the shower a gift
for his candy cane is a gift for
yes the manscape performance package 4.0
also don't record me sofia you think i
saw you
come on the manscape performance package
4.0 also includes the crop preserver and
crop reviver an anti-chafing ball
deodorant moisturizer and toner because
we need all of those things
keep his north pole feeling and smelling
fresh remember manscaped is going beyond
the groin with their new ultra premium
body wash it's infused with aloe vera
and sea salt to keep his skin feeling
clean
nice and moisturized it smells so good
you guys that i guarantee you're gonna
be wanting to use this body wash too and
guess what they also just launched their
new two-in-one shampoo and conditioner
which has key ingredients with the same
benefits that include hydrating
nourishing conditioning the scalp
strengthening his hair all at the same
time tis the season to load up on
manscape products that will actually
have you wanting to rock around his
christmas tree get 20 off and free
shipping using the code unwaxed at
manscaped.com guys that is 20
with free shipping at manscaped.com
using the code unwax that is u n w
e
naughty or nice manscaped is the number
one gift on santa's list
back for the second time on the unwaxed
podcast we have comedian writer actor
the people's channel we love that
the author behind the book advice from a
[ __ ] boy
tv world series of space yes we have the
talented clint coley baby
all right i just have to give a quick
shout out to you because when we first
started this podcast yes we were
terrible and i didn't agree with that
you know this right you said when we
first started out this podcast yes we
were terrible
no let me tell you it was really hard to
get people especially when you're
starting out doing anything to get
people to come on and support and you
were the second guest that we had on
and we can't tell you how much we
appreciated that it was still today one
of my favorite episodes actually still i
listen to it all the time i want to say
i suggested it to people when they want
to listen to the show i really
appreciate that now real quick though
y'all podcast journey was before that
like don't forget like you and i like
did a a quick teaser of you that's right
that's right like a year prior and you
kept like we just we just stayed stayed
we said yeah so um but no here's the
thing like first of all don't have i
don't believe that y'all weren't good i
believe that you guys were just starting
out and doing something that makes you
happy and now but you know at the end of
the day yeah you got to fine-tune it you
know what i'm saying totally everything
i think what the best thing that you did
when you brought to the podcast is being
super vulnerable and just saying it as
it is and we didn't learn that into
honestly 50 episodes later so now we we
talked about like what our sex
preferences are
you gotta yeah certain boundaries and
stuff like that but at the end of the
day like i've always been a fan of like
yo people wanna know who you are right
you know what i'm saying like all right
like you're sophia you're sustained but
who are you what do you like what like i
wanna feel like at the end of the day
like yo after this i can hang out with
you right you know like people people
listen to the podcast people walk up to
me and be like
clint what up i'm like who yeah they
don't matter though like the fact that
you feel comfortable calling me clint
that's what people have been doing to us
now lately a lot more which is insane
they do it in front of our parents and
we're like looking for everyone's name
who's the one who being vulnerable would
get they keep going
to be talking about all my failed dates
look at everyone to say oh i know her
now so you just mentioned that advice
from a fuckboy podcast you're not doing
it anymore but he has a book out that
it's just basically all about that i'm
assuming yeah so basically for i still
do the podcast in spurs so like
sometimes i'll throw out an episode
sometimes i won't and if we're being
super honest and vulnerable i'm gonna be
honest with everybody
when i do the podcast just know i'm
trying to promote something right like i
would be honest right like i'll give you
all an episode but
but the but the underlying he told me
the villain sells
i'm posting my i'm promoting my show
like i'm gonna go in why not like talk
i'm like i got a show in philly or a
show in new york showing that what i'm
saying um but also though i wrote the
book
because i'm like look the podcast just
don't sit with me no more mm-hmm i don't
resonate with being a [ __ ] boy i'm not
saying that i haven't been because i was
you know what i'm saying but now
i think a lot of people look at the name
of the podcast and always wanted to be
like oh well you know you're a [ __ ] boy
that's like no no no no here's what i
did
here's we're going to laugh at what i
did but we're also going to offer
solutions that's why i brought it up
because i wanted people to know that
we're not saying be a [ __ ] boy but let's
just like say if you're hanging out with
one you're acting like one this is how
to identify that you are one you're with
one and also a lot of the stories in the
book though you have to go back real
quick a lot of stories in the book come
from like stuff that i did in my 20s
right and
now those those stories are now
reflections of what i did right in my
20s you know what i'm saying and at the
end of the day like yeah no the [ __ ] is
funny like i got one story in particular
where i talk about this girl who uh long
story short i found out she was engaged
huh like i'll be like we gotta we gotta
go back rewind women got stories like
that all the time like i was on a date
on tinder and then got to find out he
was married
what happened was we was dating blah
blah blah blah blah and then long story
short i would say maybe like i forget we
we got we got into it right right a week
later a week later i see her
shut up i see her
and it's just like for you to get
engaged in a week of us breaking up
right that means that you you you've
been seeing someone on the side exactly
no way you got married in a week with it
just married and the same thing happened
to a friend of mine you know his
comedian i'm not gonna say his name on
here but the same thing happened to a
friend of mine and he was like clint
like bro it happens yeah i'm saying and
my thing is is that those stories yeah
it was funny i mean now right now but
before i actually have a question about
that if you see you found that out yes
so let's say someone's in the same
scenario they've been dating someone
they found out it's not been that long
but they were dating someone else at the
same time that you guys were like
messing around do you say something in
the moment i wanted to tell a fiance so
bad like see i wasn't safe do you tell
the fiancee
no because then that puts another level
of of a situation on it that you don't
need to be involved
so like think about it like this you go
and tell this man's wife like hey or
this man's fiance hey yo you knew he was
[ __ ] me right yeah which is fine but
at the end of the day you're still not
gonna be with him anyway right you know
i mean and you think and she's probably
still going to be with him yeah
like that's the thing because she has a
ring she has something tan you look like
a hater also karma comes around she's
going to get caught one day she will
yeah she's going to get cheated
100
so when you first came on the show
you
identified yourself as a former fuckboy
you said i was i was into that lifestyle
i'm not out here doing that anymore
what is your identity now because it's
almost been over a year since we've seen
you yeah yeah yeah
what's happening man no listen my
situation now is i'm a one-woman guy no
no yeah
are you single right now no
no
okay so how did you meet your
significance damn you know what's funny
i never talked about it probably i've
never had right well now you're on a
boxing board right i know right um nah
we just you know we we
shh
next question
no we've been we were friends we've been
friends for a very long time i've known
her
questions about that yeah i've been
heard for over 10 years of my life but
never here's the thing that we were
never romantic
throughout the we were never romantic
like we were legit
friends like well my question is how did
you know
that there could be you know something
sexual there because you have this
friendship for today and i'm fine let's
let's start that's true that's true
right but you've had this friendship for
10 years
and you're gonna possibly risk it all
and if it doesn't work out then you
can't really go back to the way it was
neither one of us really cared wow
like that's the problem like you know
i'm glad we talking about this this is a
very good topic when we talk about
friends becoming lovers like yeah
everybody in here or everybody whether
you straight get whatever you've had
that situation
here's here's how you do it
you can't think of like we always think
about the worst possible outcome
i could lose my friend yeah like we
could it would never be the same again
and you're absolutely right but here's
the other part you ever bet on something
and you be right that's a good feeling
like you ever bet on something like that
yeah about whoever you have a special oh
you you bet
like but nobody else believed in it but
you know you was you was dead
right like there's nothing better than
like think about and well not related to
sports
think about guys we like we're not
talking about lebron james or anybody
like we knew they were talented but
think about a guy like a like a damien
lillard or a guy like who's been who
would have looked over his entire career
but somebody was like
nah yeah he got it he's that guy like
yeah and you were right right you know
and i i feel like that's how dating your
friend is it's like yeah there's a high
risk like yeah you might y'all but
here's the thing you're a good person
you're a good person i like to think i'm
a good person yeah do we make mistakes
and do we not consider each other's
feelings at that point we're not going
to go through stuff absolutely but why
shouldn't it work
if it but let's just say it doesn't it
shouldn't be because we're not friends
it just should be we we're just not fit
as lovers all right but at least we try
you guys date you guys have sex all that
stuff and then you end it can you guys
go back to being friends
you can go back any goopy going back to
friends after seeing each other naked
yes
you think so that is me
i've heard the opposite there's a
plethora of female friends in my life
right now who i've seen ass naked
you know uh face down
you know
now you need to [ __ ] now i'm in trouble
but no he's like we're back no but like
no but there's women who but they're
married and we're still friends we're
good we cool i think that's a level of
maturity but yeah but yeah we're not
seeing with the people that we hang out
yeah but like did you see that she's
like we ain't there yet we're not there
yet is there something that you did or
someone that they is there something
that you guys said to each other that
was like no we're going to keep this we
just
negative we just didn't end with [ __ ]
you we didn't
i hate you yeah yeah
yeah
and we we ended with this isn't working
right well you know what i have to say
again going back to the first time you
came on you gave really good snippets of
what to say when you want to approach
someone and when you want to end things
with them
no you were so good at it
that response right there is a
tell-telling sign of it um sophia and i
always have a problem where
if we want to end things
we always just think the easiest way to
do it is to just ghost them yeah no it's
not bad it's not that it's bad it's just
it always leaves a unsettling or like a
yeah okay you ever i mean i don't know
if you've ever done this but like they
might walk in somewhere and somebody owe
you money but it's like you feel but
like it'll be like but it don't be like
a thousand dollars it'd be like a hunt
you know you know you owe me 100 yeah
but i don't need a hundred dollars that
bad where i'm not going to sweat it yeah
but you know what i know like we're at a
restaurant right and it's time to pay
like you get covered
it's 48 you just you want to see what
they're gonna do you know what i'm
saying and it's like but you don't say
nothing yeah you know you just let it go
because at the end of the day
it's not worth it yeah i say that to say
it's kind of the same thing when you do
that it's like you ghost them and then
it's all but there's always that back of
your mind you know what the [ __ ] you did
that's so true my thing is it's easier
just be honest if you just say hey like
oh this isn't working now here's the
thing the problem is we've been trained
to feel like friends is is second place
or friends is a bad thing right fellas
for fellas that listen to this podcast
if you [ __ ]
if you [ __ ] you didn't fail
like really think about that if you
you're you are you say it one more time
you're not in the friend zone
i mean that is kind of a win like you
[ __ ] like you did you didn't lose like
it's just that it's better that we're
friends because we're not working
[ __ ] true we're gonna make merch with
that
do it yeah please do it do it i'm
encouraging you so then as friends with
benefits possible true friends
no i don't but i don't
know
why you know why why because both of you
guys are still like you're not y'all
still in the space of
like
i like we're friends with benefits but
somebody's going to catch feelings
there's always something that catches
that's okay though yeah it's it's not
about the catching feelings is the
problem mm-hmm it's navigating those
feelings yeah think about it like this
right right you're both beautiful women
thank you let's just say we're let's
just say so let's just say you and i
friends were better yeah we'll just play
role play right at the end of the day
right
you're my friend i got i like for me to
want to sleep with you that's it i would
have to have
a romantic it's somewhat of a
man of interest yeah but i do know i
don't have the space
to maybe be more or whatever right yeah
so here's what we do
not every time we have sex but like as a
man fellas it's your job to check in
right hey hey is this getting too much
for you you okay right like are you cool
with this or every time like you know
what i'm saying like if you constantly
like here's the thing people like to say
communication is the key because y'all
communicate up front right what about
what goes on in between the first
conversation in the last couple years
yeah you got to consistently communicate
because feelings change well this is the
thing i've actually talked to a couple
friends i've had this scenario and she
was like seeing her best friend it's no
not me not really
is that they never communicated really
what was going on the situation so her
feelings are hurt and then he's just
kind of like well i just wanted to like
[ __ ] her out you know what it is and so
this that's the problem is like you're
not being concise and like very very
open about what's going on the
friendship is going to be [ __ ] in the
end exactly so here's the thing if you
guys aren't cons like here's the thing
right i'm i communicate with my friends
even my unromantic friends you know what
i mean like you communicate you also
like here's the thing we gotta let's be
real like you guys are sisters right
outside of anything else y'all go
through y'all still have to talk like
y'all you're not always getting along
y'all got to talk mm-hmm you know what
i'm saying like hey so like i don't like
the way this is going asis i don't like
like
we have to so that's where friends with
benefits come into play right anytime
i've ever been friends with benefits
with a woman i've always
talked to him throughout the throughout
the situationship so that at any moment
you feel like yo you know what clint
this is getting too much i gotta go and
yeah what if that's not happening what
if the conversation is not happening and
someone's treating the other person kind
of like [ __ ] and knows their friend then
you gotta go okay and that's it then
we're not friends yeah you're treating
me like [ __ ] right and we're not friends
you know what i'm saying
that's that's what i don't think and
here's the thing we're friends serious
you know what i'm saying i take that i
really like so promising like you're
asking me how i can stay friends with
women i've i've slept with like i'll
give one girl a person
in in particular she's my best friend
yeah i mean like actually she's the you
know i i mean i told her i'd stop saying
the story you know i'm not gonna do it
right no i'm gonna do it [ __ ] it hey
yeah yeah
[ __ ] you
my godson's mother yeah right now mind
you she's engaged blah blah blah blah
back in when we were in college right we
we did that
but we're friends you know why because
we communicated we talked about it and
also i i also i can legit look in the
camera and say i have zero romantic
feelings for her and vice versa there's
no underlying yeah like she's about to
get married i'm going to be at the
wedding i'm happy for her she's pregnant
right now i'm happy for her what if
someone's feelings get hurt when you
establish that friendship afterwards
it's the ego that gets in the way
like how do you fix that can you
edit this become the villain it comes
back to fellas it always says if you
[ __ ]
you're not you didn't lose yeah but what
if you didn't [ __ ]
if you didn't [ __ ] you lost
but i always feel like in this situation
i always feel like in this situation
guys are made the villains yes and you
look like the bad guy for being honest
when you're really just communicating
the problem is the people that we're
hanging out with their emotional
intelligence is very low here it is and
you you're so good at communicating and
saying it's a long time 34 now so when
did you
sort of start to figure that out when i
was 34. okay right no place it's like
you know but no literally like it didn't
happen so like my emotional intelligence
and i'm still not and people will be
like clint emotional childhood [ __ ] you
be you i mean god where will you be you
be you i'll be flying off the handle
i'll be you know what i'm saying i'm
yeah you know there's i have my moments
i don't like like i don't want nobody to
think i'm perfect yeah right but
when i turned 30 yeah it changed
because my patience got different with
people here's one thing that did change
me too right so over the pandemic we had
to realize one thing like yo
like everybody's going through something
and we got to give each other grace and
space for things that happen and don't
happen right
so like says let me uh sophie says let's
say again we're back to you let's say
again we're we're friends with benefits
yeah and you said clint this doesn't
work for me anymore right
i have to take my personal feelings out
of whatever you whatever i feel for you
you're not doing it
trying to hurt me right you're doing it
because you can't get hurt
right you see what i'm saying and you
can't do this anymore yeah this doesn't
work for you if i'm your real friend
then i should respect it like that and
understand that you know what i'm saying
yeah i'm your and if i lose you as a
friend because of that then we would
never know when our friends in the first
place that's the bottom line the stone
cold said so oh damn
i honestly hate to see it but i respect
it now
i know you're no longer a [ __ ] boy
but
but
sophia and i
love to play games because we sometimes
feel like games you know what i mean
that part of the relationship when it's
this cat and mouse chase it could be a
lot of fun did you personally hate when
women like is there a certain game that
a woman played that really got under
your skin in a good way and you're like
oh i love that she's teasing me or
something that she's doing is really
just
winding me up in the right way yeah i
like the women who or i did like the
women who were like
i've done the make out at my spot and
then like we did nothing
and that was like i've done that as like
a grown grown man not just at like 16.
like i did like i did it at like 29.
right you know what i'm saying
and the only reason i like that game is
because the best part about sex people
really don't that is underrated is the
anticipation yeah
100 it's always the it's like that's the
best part of sex it's not that i it's i
mean
climax is great but the anticipation
like the the
you know what i'm saying like totally so
she knew in the back of her mind i
wanted to sleep with him i'm going to
sleep
just that not today i know there's
something about keeping a mystery there
and also there's a way though but like
she did it in such a way where it didn't
make me feel like she didn't want to
have sex
but like she was purposely not prepared
to have yeah so that once we got to a
certain level it didn't matter what i
did we wasn't doing it right
so that that is a good game because i
always feel like sometimes it's good to
hold off and like kind of build up the
anticipation and also keep them thinking
like is she gonna do it today like he's
gonna have to keep working at it and he
won't stick like he's gonna stick around
if he wants it so what do you think
about the games when in terms of the
early stages texting like going back and
forth are you one of those people that
are like yeah wait an hour or you like
just answer when you answer i'm kind of
on the fence about that
if you're not responding just to not
seem like you're desperate that's corny
as [ __ ] stop it god damn it that is
corny as [ __ ] like if you think yeah
that's corny if you like me and i like
you like answer the phone man i agree
that's it like what are we gonna agree
you don't you don't because here's the
thing
if somebody thinks you're desperate for
answering quick then let them think that
that's not the person you need to be
yeah like that's like here's the thing
we we all say to ourselves like a crush
is a great thing everybody i love like
that is that's one thing about being
single that's always been it's so fun
having a crush oh crush a nice yeah it
is and it's like it then like when you
finally get to meet each other y'all
talking or y'all y'all
yeah like
do it right yeah that's thomas precious
what did i say to you on the way here
your time
here are you ignoring somebody right now
all right so you don't even know you
asked me if i was single and we're gonna
air that so i'm super single she's not
single anymore i know you're not like no
no it's funny because
she's in like a full relationship she's
watching me with my friggin
takeoffs and landings like crash
landings and this is the problem last
time you left sophia she's been in the
same position
no literally but
the problem is i'm going on these like
average days for these guys that's just
not working so let me ask you an honest
question who are you dating not who but
like i don't want you no i know um give
me the kind of guys that you
they're just
usually the guys that go out with are
not the guys that i want because i know
that i can control them
and i'm a lot scarier i think think
right like would you say a girl guys are
not like
you are definitely intimidating on a
date because uh she doesn't shut up
but you know that but all the guys are
nice
you're not shutting up means that you
okay you know actually i have a change
of answer i take that back everyone's
super nice they're all my age
i don't think that has to do with
anything honestly why it's just that
sophie and i have a habit of owning the
conversation
and then we don't let them speak and
then we don't realize their personality
until five days no and the guy and the
guy doesn't ever take and the guy does
never take charge like we'll be going on
a date he'll be like meet me there
and then oh you kind of pay for half of
it or you i'm like this is like the
third date here like look i'm not saying
that i need to be like courted for four
years but i'm saying with the first five
dates
you better treat me like a queen i i'm
sorry i know that sounds kind of cheesy
no no no no there's nothing wrong with
that i think there's two parts there's
two parts to that so number one you do
know like you know because you know your
last name does that that that's that's
part of it like guys are intimidated off
the rip like you just you got to deal
with that but and i mean i'm taking that
out
and the second part is though and let's
just
put this on the table
a lot of times guys
don't know how to assert themselves as a
like as like hey like i'm taking you out
yes and hey like here's the thing we
they listen to so much bad information
on how to treat women and they think
that we treat like here's the problem
fellas
we treat women all the same and you
can't do that no the guy you're in love
with or whatever your guy you're with
right now treated you special he
realized he he wanted to date sistine he
didn't want to date he wasn't treating
you like he was dating [ __ ] he was
dating you yeah so at the end of the day
we're in an era where we're we're more
woke and we're more advanced and we're
more smarter we're more intelligent
emotionally we're more in tune with like
how to treat people we're more in tune
with therapy and trauma and blah blah
blah blah and now women are like oh oh
my guy
you're not going to treat me like that
right that's true and guys are like whoa
whoa whoa [ __ ] why can't i treat you
like this that's the divide right now
indeed so okay let's just say you're
going out with a guy then that does
treat you like every other girl do you
say something or just let it go just
move on
if you fee okay see here's the thing you
got to differentiate sometimes and this
is on women now i'ma hold you
accountable yeah you have to be a better
judge of character in a sense of
knowing that this is either this is
genuine or this is just
this is just extra
and here's how you know it's genuine i'm
about to give you the secret right now
you know it's genuine
because you can tell how much of your
time he how much of his time you have
men are very very very particular with
their time like literally like i have a
podcast with multiple podcasts i have a
show i have this i'm a stan i gotta do
all these things but at the end of the
night who do i want to [ __ ] talk to
who do i want to share with you
i mean yeah that's the that's the bottom
line right who do i want to end my night
with who do i want to who's the last
person i want to talk to or who's or who
am i talking to when i have time
to to downtime right do you have down
time you're not right that's really what
it comes down to is that a telltale sign
that you're probably dating an f-boy and
someone that isn't actually wanting to
commit to you well it's not even more so
committing it's more so like we make we
all make time for what we want to we
we've already heard that right yeah
right but tom people don't realize is
that's how much how much currency that
really takes it's true you know what i'm
saying yeah because at the end of the
day
i have a long day blah blah blah blah i
may not want to talk to nobody but i'm
going to talk to you right
i mean sophie and i always say if he
wanted to he would yeah that's it it's
really the only question
yeah like that's it if you want like
listen we work in entertainment
i didn't get anything in this business
because i was talented
i got everything in this business
because i worked my ass off and i showed
companies and people and blah blah blah
blah blah what my value is and that's
how i was able to break through it or
break through a certain point right and
the thing that that same
idea and that same
that same
has to has to be applied to dating right
and i'm not saying fellas you got to go
above beyond of what everybody else is
doing you just need to show her hey look
i like you i like you i want your time
right and can i give you mine you know
what i totally agree i sometimes feel
like guys over complicate and they think
we
because y'all do too yeah well that's
true we definitely overthink and
overcome okay you know i do 100 true
but from from our experience they think
that we
sometimes want more and we're really
simple creatures yeah if you just say
let's go get a bottle of wine from the
market a slice of pizza and just talk
we're so happy with that
and also girls notice the time you're
putting into it because i notice the
time that you're taking to go pick me up
i'm noticing the time you're sitting and
talking
always
it's really the little things what's the
first thing y'all notice when y'all
walked up to me at the stu when we when
i first walked in the studio
because i respect your time exactly you
said the podcast started at 12. you know
what i mean that don't mean i get there
at 12 that means it starts at 12 and i
don't know what other technical things
y'all got going on i mean we showed up
at 11 50 and we're like oh [ __ ] he's you
by the way you have been the only guest
early and on time yeah well because at
the end of the day like you and i'm
coming from long beach too so i won like
like not to say that you know y'all
gotta no no
i'm happy to be here i want to do as
many episodes i love y'all
but what i'm saying is that i i like i
value your time yeah right if i didn't
want to be here i'm gonna be i'm gonna
be late yeah you know what i mean or
think about it when you don't want to do
something you want to be someone you're
good [ __ ] no you're like it's true you
don't get [ __ ] that's true
like because like so prime example real
quick i'm sorry i keep talking no no
girl got mad at me because like she was
30 minutes late on the date i left she's
like why are you leaving blah blah i
said you didn't give me a heads up you
didn't tell me in advance you showed up
30 minutes late you know what i'm saying
but here's the thing right and i know
let's not equate we could equate it to
jobs and not but you know damn well if
your boss tells you if or not your boss
but if you're going for a job interview
and you got to be there at 11 45 or they
said it's 11 45 your ass won't be there
at 10 30. yeah seriously this is our
first are we 11 30. this is our first
birthday
i'm not saying
do i give grace for five minutes yes
yeah do i give grace for 10 minutes yes
do i give grace for 15 minutes with a
phone call like hey yeah
right that's cool for you to show up 30
minutes late then ask me what's wrong
with you [ __ ] i think that is so
disrespectful disrespectful yeah so i
say that to say like
when guys like you mm-hmm they show you
with their time yeah i mean that's it's
so well put i mean like you can't even
equate it to like texting like the last
minute what do you want to do tonight
like no did you plan something already
out did you take the time to find it
well here's the thing now let's real
quick with that though last minute does
not always mean you're second place
last minute doesn't mean because here's
here's ladies i want you to guys i'm
fair i keep it open
fellas
i mean i'm sorry ladies
understand this
95 percent of men i'm speaking with i'm
talking there's three guys there's three
guys in this room i've never met two of
them
most men we suck at planning y'all yeah
we just that's just not what we do oh we
know we live with our cousin and we love
all the dates we just don't we can't
like when it comes to work stuff we can
plan yeah but when it comes to women's
stuff you know why we can't plan because
we're scared to mess up right we're
scared
i swear it's really we just don't want
to [ __ ] like we don't want to take you
to the wrong restaurants we don't want
to do like it's literally just we don't
know but it's true we have had such a
different change of perspective since
living with our cousin because he's
literally like i have no idea where to
start i don't know where to go where to
take her what to order and we tell him
exactly what to do he'll do the same
thing 400 times the same girl because he
doesn't know what other thing to do
because it's the one that works and when
women say you know did you plan and
stuff like that we understand ladies
that planning is the above and beyond
yeah but please give us some space to
say like okay if we text you say hey
what you're doing tonight and you're
like oh that shouldn't be taste should
be making plans well we don't know what
give him some grace you don't know what
he you know what i'm saying mm-hmm so
now if you you're saying nothing you
know you tell them nothing i got no
plans blah blah blah he's like hey what
would you like to hang out you know and
then that's when you say what do you
have in mind i don't know but i just
want to see you
like if if he's saying that and if it's
not on something like i'm trying to [ __ ]
if it's really just i want to hang out
with you right yeah ladies there's
nothing wrong with making some plans i
actually have a question for you and i
feel like you're the right guy to answer
so uh
we posted a few of the clips from our
previous episode on our tick tock of you
in it and like the responses were great
and that actually blew up and it was
great i posted uh another video of
me and this one girl from a netflix show
two ought to handle and sophia oh i like
that show by the way harley lawrence the
blonde
the clip was us saying
if a girl gets ready for a date and she
spends
two hours getting ready she gets her
nails done she gets her hair dynamite
it's a whole thing it's expensive and
the first thing that you don't say to
her when you see her is oh you look so
beautiful like
you don't unders even if you don't
believe it it really just makes her
whole day because that's what she's
waiting for
and the comments
all men were so oh you want us to lie
you're a walking red flag
they all destroyed me oh so you want me
to lie to you okay i'll lie to you and
it's like do you think that's a bad
thing to ask for to to like do you think
yeah maybe right oh god i am a walking
red flag who is that because
i love when i go on a date because i
don't think it's a walking perfect i'm
gonna disagree with you
i think it's great when i come out from
a date where i'm like i've been thinking
about it all day girls think about it
all day girls think about this date all
day they make sure their hair is ready
their nails ready to cough i don't care
if it's like you half-ass it or you
full-blown it like would i do it but i
appreciate when a guy goes you look
beautiful tonight like sophia the other
day was like i put my hair in rollers
for this guy and it turned out bad yeah
so that's why i like when i come out and
he says something sweet like that and
that's maybe a preference thing but i do
think it completely changes the tone of
the date because the girl remembers it
so why do you disagree all right uh-oh
here's where i disagree
it's not here's the thing
right
like we do the same thing though ladies
you know i mean like this is this is
where this is where it gets interesting
right
we think all day we think about what we
going to wear we call our homeboys we
lay our outfits out like everything you
think really yes everything you think
you do before
guys do the same i have a get ready for
a date playlist like i take it serious
man yes i'm getting a haircut
guys think of it as in depth as girls
like yourself
i always thought guys are like that's
the thing women think we like we're just
like women think we're heartless
emotionless creatures i thought you guys
just like shower brush your hair put on
like but it's not it's not your fault
it's just the men okay even me coming
here like and i'm not even just saying
that because i'm on camera like no like
i was intentional about what i was
wearing i got all my philly's hat i'm
wearing red and my sneakers yeah i
wanted my shirt to say bull because i'm
from philly that's what we say like yeah
yeah like like i like my thing is when i
do stuff i always want to say oh i'm
from philly like you know what i'm
saying like that that's that's something
that represents but i take that i take
that seriously but i say all that to say
when we got a date if we got plans we
try to impress you yeah we're trying to
smell good and here's the thing
we don't we don't guys don't walk into a
date saying if she don't compliment me
the date's over
she don't compliment me
that's the problem
we look for the wrong thing
i just got school school of like yeah
here's the thing you said the right
thing though okay you you she's like uh
here's where i agreed on him i agree you
said and my man will agree to you said
well if he does compliment me though we
remember that and it changes the tone of
the date
meaning
that guys
we should do that we are going to do
that for the most part
we are paying it to like you know what
i'm saying
especially if you notice like notice
something like notice her nails or
notice something yeah very small always
that works we know that but here's the
thing we may not be even thinking about
that because we're so so nervous not to
say nothing stupid oh that's kind of
scary you don't understand like what
kind of like that's what i really wanna
like let's let's hone in on that real
quick ladies you don't know how nervous
guys be on dates hands be sweaty we be
like yo we we the same insecurities
y'all have then blah blah blah yo like
bro like me and my homeboys like my
homeboy go on a date hey somebody like
yo it's our first day i'm gonna call
them after i want it i want details
right guys we asked the same thing like
before they went called we coached each
other like yo bro you know i mean you
know do it yeah i mean when you go in
there you know first thing first make
sure you we do that
but see what we don't tell you that
because why do y'all need to know that
we tell everyone how look at us no it
doesn't seem you're worried about like
that's the thing women a lot of times
y'all think y'all y'all so selfless
you're really not sometimes y'all only
think about it from your own perspective
it's true like y'all have no idea guys
being like sofia i i guarantee you're a
beautiful young lady
your last day i guarantee you it was the
first date he was terrified
not because you were probably dominating
the conversation or anything like that
some guys are even just so in awe of the
fact that we dating you
like a lot of guys feel like like and i
don't know oh you should call them we're
out your league like someone's
oh my gosh she did it this morning
please it's too late damn it's too late
no it's not it's not too late it's never
here's the thing like really like we've
been looking at women sometimes y'all so
fine like how the [ __ ] we do this
how that's true you really don't want to
mess it up because you know why we don't
we know y'all got options
you know you y'all think we got so many
options we really don't
we really don't like yo it'd be like we
probably had maybe one and a possible
but you know what it is i think it's
women have this mindset that
like you're gonna eventually leave us
for someone else or you're gonna have a
wandering eye because of our history
with previous men that have had a
wonderful well here's the thing we're
not going to sit here act like guys
don't have a wandering eye we're not
going to act like we have a wandering
idea
as well
but here's the thing it happens but
we're just talking about from the
initial first date and just like just
like the problem is we're thinking seven
eight steps down the road think of the
night we're having we're trying to have
a good night if y'all just have a good
night
that's it sophia just have a good night
thank you for saying that that's all you
need to do push your microphone you're
done
interview's done i'll tell you what
sophia's problem is she honestly i
sometimes i just say she goes i don't
want to date this guy because i don't
see a future with him and like our paths
don't
[Laughter]
she goes i'm not going out with him
because his chest hair was patchy
i saw a photo of his patchy chest hair
and i got sophia that is
the absolute wrong
see that though so she's a stalker
other story that is chest hair so you
don't want to go on because he has
patchy chest hair literally but the
problem
how do we know you don't have patchy
chestnuts
can you imagine us going on a date we
get you home and sofia got patchy chest
hair
i'll be mad as [ __ ] and then you're like
why don't you accept me for me
i agree i agree the problem is you i did
you could that was a bad one she she
will look at a first date like it is the
next 10 years of her life instead of
just going on the date for the company
it's one night
that's all it is if we then here's the
thing
if you want it to be more it could be
more
but let's just get through the night
like here's what here's how a date
normally goes like let's be real a date
goes you know let's we let's say we
don't pick you up let's say we meet
there yeah and the reason why guys are
iffy about picking you up is because
there's been a lot of women who said hey
you don't you don't want us to know
where we where you live and be it's a
safety thing if something goes wrong on
a date you want to be able to get up get
up and yeah you know like not take me
home this is like this is yeah we live
in a totally different area era and
women's safety is definitely a priority
yeah so let's so let's go a step further
now
so the first part of the day let's just
say we getting something to eat
six o'clock get something to eat but
dinner went well you got plans after
this
neither do i
we just we i enjoy talking to you
i don't want to end the night what's
next
drinks i'm just kidding no
wait where let's go
like
a bar
i'm just saying where's your favorite
place i'm not saying
we're assuming that
my friend
yeah cause you're not you're so worried
about you're so worried about five years
down the road i i i didn't get what's
going on is anyone home no i got
confused i was like
no yeah i didn't say we were role played
that's that's not no no sorry i thought
you were just like talking
hypothetically
oh sorry so let's start again because
we'll see she's like take two thank you
sorry i'm sorry about that like no
you're good no i didn't say you're
asking oh where are we going after so i
would make the suggestion like where are
we going you could but
it doesn't but the fact that you want to
see me after this yeah okay i got you
guys then like we can continue to date
and we just keep having fun and yeah all
right i'll see you i'll see you later i
text you when i get home talk tomorrow
like literally i have a meme that says
you know you ask her out she says yes
you ask her when you ask her when she's
free y'all go out you have fun you you
you do that [ __ ] again why the [ __ ] is
that so difficult it's not but why do we
make it so difficult i i make it
difficult because like i want a guy to
pick me up i want a guy to there's a lot
of i think there's a lot of expectations
but also you got to if you if that's
what if that's what you want yeah you
can say that
but you know it also goes back to us
creating scenarios and
and
assuming things in our head and
expectations in our head and when they
don't meet them
we immediately get turned off but they
don't know that we're creating those
things and
it's all make-believe we're really just
self-sabotaging right yeah like think
about it if you like how somebody's
supposed to know what you're what you
want like here's the thing but it feels
weird to say to a guy that i'm just
starting to see hey i would really
appreciate it if you picked me up how's
that weird i just feel like it's forced
like i want him to want to it's not that
we don't want to though like here's the
things like okay i'm gonna go again role
play right
let's i'm gonna i'm gonna hypothetically
say you and i are dating okay the first
question wouldn't be i will ask the
picture pick you up you know why because
i know you might not want me no you
don't need every guy don't need to know
where you live yeah you know what i'm
saying the stuff like i'm going to
assume we're just going to meet up but
you want to be picked up but if you say
hey
clint can you pick me up it's not that i
don't want to do it just say that if you
if i pick you up that means more time
spent with you so i don't lose in that
situation let's set the record straight
if a girl asks for what she wants and
she's being direct
guys won't think it's
aggressive or tone you can't say you
better pick me up or pick me to [ __ ] up
or something like that you just let her
just be like hey hey would you mind hey
i hate so many dates that i just can't
what's wrong with you okay
the woman just said to you hey you know
i know we got plans would you mind
picking me up are you tripping
we're good that's a thumbs up we were
good oh no
we're good and if he says no guess what
i'm staying home because i you know what
i'm like you said yes that's the problem
this is like my issue and i feel like a
lot of women probably can relate to this
is you create the scenarios in your head
and you're just thinking oh my god that
i have and that's going to be the
perfect one for me is going to be that
guy that picks me up and i don't even
have to ask him for like and if her
butts or he's going to make the
reservation without me asking like he's
always going to know the right thing to
do for me yeah exactly and sometimes
exactly and sometimes i think and i'm
just like speaking i'm like realizing
things about myself
you get lucky if you find that guy that
can just do that instantly that's just
luck i mean like
every person like a girl and a guy they
all need a little training we wrote this
down because i feel like since everyone
is online and like even in person
there's a lot of games
verbally and i feel like you're a smooth
talker so you know exactly the
translation of what every of these [ __ ]
boy or girls are saying all right let me
hear you really excited let's wrap up
the show with a fun little game
you're the best person to play with
we're going to call it what are you
trying to say what are you trying to say
what are you trying to say we're gonna
give you
common phrases
from men and women all right that you
hear all the time and you're gonna
translate for us rapid pace all right
exactly what the truth is behind that
phrase i'm ready sophia started
i'm not looking for a relationship i'm
not looking for a relationship that's
exactly what you're trying to say okay
you're saying it you're not like that's
the problem we be trying to like you
know
feel that out no if you say that i
believe that there or see i was thinking
i'm not looking for a relationship with
you only reason why because i've been
the person who's not looking for i
really didn't want it it was it had
nothing okay
uh you deserve better than me means i
don't want to break your
heart but i don't know you deserve
better than me means i really don't want
to be with you no more okay it really
means i deserve better than you
there we go
there we go i deserve better to you all
right so this is if they haven't been
answering whatever i've just been busy
swamped with work i've been [ __ ]
somebody else okay
fair
i hate pda
i love pda oh oh my god
he's like personally oh
yeah i hate pa i'm on the fence with
that because there are people who just
hate that [ __ ] like i agree but the
first thing that came to my head was
they want to seem they want yeah
unavailable and in public no they want
to seem yeah unavailable no i don't
think it's that i think because like
there's people who really get like now
me i don't i ain't telling you down in
public but like i'm yeah i'm a whole
hands i'm a grab ass but some people
aren't like that just right right i've
and i've been with women who weren't
like that see i've been with guys that
don't want to seem taken
so that they will oh yeah that's that
yeah no that's not that doesn't go for
everybody though so i okay just some
just um if a girl says i'm fine i'm fine
no you're not fine what about a guy
saying i'm fine we're not fine we're not
no one's fine nobody's fine everybody
we're fine it's cool it's definitely not
cool all right okay definitely not cool
i don't post who i date on social media
that oh man you get it you hit the nail
on the head with that that's me right
now oh wow
i don't that's a it's it's a safety
thing like i will be honest what you
like
people are crazy i agree with people
that's crazy like i get it it does give
a red flag yeah but
i've been consistent with that my entire
social media life i've
i totally agree i've never posted a
relationship because of a safety thing
we've had problems in the past but say
if you're not
in the entertainment world
and you're just a
regular nine-to-five job yeah right
right like what does that mean that
means i got a girlfriend
oh i got a boyfriend probably
probably there we go
we have a good thing going and i don't
want to ruin it with the label
i want to continue seeing other people
oh god it hurts damn burns
all right during the breakup they say
but i still want you in my life i still
want [ __ ] oh yes
that's true that is you nailed it um
congratulations you won the game
absolutely
our listeners love you yeah i [ __ ] with
y'all and and now i'm invested in your
dating life so like i'm gonna definitely
help me out here oh my god i need
someone to hold her account this podcast
has really opened my eyes to things i've
been really doing wrong and now i feel
really guilty for everything yeah i'm
going i'm definitely going to hit you
with text just see oh geez
yeah i got it i'm gonna just randomly
text you are you overthinking yeah yes
please
honestly ask me in a week if i'm still
going out with trustee here or apache
chester
chest hair guys thank you guys for
joining us thank you wait
find your book your show everything yeah
the advice refugee book it's on amazon
prom i actually have a book i have books
at home i'm going to give both of you
guys one thank you great yeah i need it
okay so next time i come here i got a
book for you like they're in my house
and my my thing but yeah if anybody will
get a book so on amazon prom um you get
it like you get it you order today you
get it tomorrow
um
and uh i got a show called the world
series of spades uh debut in december
uh first december first so amazing thank
you guys so for those y'all to play
spades card game and we'll link all of
that in the bio put your instagram there
please we adore you thank you so much
coming back i love you guys yeah it was
awesome bye guys we'll see you next
tuesday
[Music]